Aaron where were you in your life when
this role for Kevin Rooney was presented
to uh I was right here in those an
Achilles and I met Ben the director came
and saw me and presented this to me
Myles and I had worked together before
on a movie called rabbit hole and so I
was happy to reunite with him and I love
the story I love the comeback story I
love the guy that dreams big I love the
the family element in this you know the
sacred bond of trainer fighter so I was
and I loved boxing so I was very happy
to do it where did you go inside of your
own experiences to develop or work on
the character of Kevin well I mean you
know boxers or you know they're they
sacrifice dedication discipline you know
I find that I have that in my own life
with my own career you know it takes a
fighters mentality to you know to work
in this business and we share that and
then I went to a local trainer here one
of the greatest trainers in the world
Freddie Roach and I went through Manny
Pacquiao and versus Bradley their
training camp and Freddie taught me
everything he knows about about being a
trainer whispering in the ear doing the
mitts you know giving him water the
chess game that you play so I got a
pretty good good education and then I
found unfortunately Kevin Rooney is in
the hospital with dementia and so I
wasn't able to work with him but I
worked with his son and I learned as
much as I could about him and and put it
on screen well I know you've talked
before I believe about like dark and
light characters and how often the
audience relates more to the dark
character because maybe they feel more
comfortable
I think people you know we're all
riddled by fear and doubt and insecurity
and we all have dreams we talk ourselves
out of those dreams you know that's what
life's about adversity and and those
usually I mean people could obviously
relate to those characters you know
they're complex but they're also more
entertaining you know because they're
struggling and we like to you know this
is a comeback story so we want it we
like to see people who've been on the
top and have fallen down fallen from
grace and then picking themselves
I always say there's no such thing as
second chances you get as many chances
as you want in this world it's what it's
how you present yourself to the world
that gives you the second chance you can
continually reinvent yourself but you've
got to do it and this is a story about
two guys and a whole family who who
picked themselves off the mat and
reinvent themselves it's about a guy who
gets in a car accident breaks his neck
and becomes a middleweight champion of
the world afterwards and it's never been
done before so there's a lot of you know
good you know thematics going on in this
movie how do you think people relate to
Kevin's character I think I love him I
think that he's a free spirit
he loves his fighter you know you can
see that he they have a great love for
each other you know he has his demons
you know he's fighting his demons he's
living vicariously through Vinny he's a
colorful guy I think they like him a lot
he's pretty funny transformation yeah
thank you very much